buongiorno modomodo no perché non solo
luca ha deciso di non presentarmi per
non spezzare la magia creata dal talk
della ragazzina ma mi ha anche messo a
parlare dopo colei che evidentemente era
più dotata fra gli speaker che oggi che
oggi avete sentite da testa a testa da
testa a testa
ora togliamoci subito un possibile
equivoco le teste di cui parlo non solo
la mia e la vostra non è qualche cosa
che dalla mia testa io voglio fare
arrivare alla vostra la storia di due
teste quella di un ingegnere è quella di
una bambina un ingegnere una bambina per
capire un pochino di cosa sto parlando
facciamo un passo indietro e partiamo da
una domanda che sicuramente qualcuno di
voi ho tutti voi vi siete vi sarete
posti davanti a un oggetto un prodotto
un servizio qualche cosa e la domanda è
ma com'è possibile che questo costi così
poco costi così poco un cellulare un
cestino di mirtilli che vediamo che
arrivano dal cile trovate qui il mercato
e ci chiediamo ma com'è possibile che
costi così poco
questa è la domanda intelligente perché
sposta l'attenzione da quello che si
chiama valore attribuito dall'utente in
quella che gli anglosassoni usare user
perspective al valore commisurato alla
quantità di investimento che è stata
necessaria per produrre quel qualcosa o
quell'oggetto quindi è un modo diverso
di ragionare noi veniamo educati a stare
dalla parte del consumatore e abbiamo
pronto cassa un sistema contabile che è
il prezzo che è il prezzo molto semplice
molto comodo con cui possiamo
confrontare qualsiasi cosa però
qualche volta veramente ci ci viene da
dire ma caspita come può costare così
poco questo oggetto
ripeto la domanda è intelligente
l'esempio più classico e quello del
petrolio
abbiamo una bottiglia di petrolio
bottiglie d'acqua immaginate la
bottiglia di petrolio da botti di
petrolio ha richiesto che una serie di
persone altamente qualificate degli
ingegneri facessero delle prospezioni
minerarie imposti sicuramente disagevoli
su cui lavorare fino a che non hanno
trovato qualche cosa hanno chiamato un
sacco di tecnici un sacco di
apparecchiature hanno scavato un pozzo
profondo chilometri hanno estratto il
petrolio l'hanno messo in contenitori è
stato trasportato una raffineria e sulla
costa
da lì è stato messo sulle petroliere è
arrivato in italia sono stati pagati i
dazi doganali e questa bottiglia di
petrolio costa 20 centesimi al litro
l'acqua di contro sudista che sto per
fare una sola semplificazione tanto per
capirci l'acqua di conto andate a scorzè
fonte del san benedetto
mettete chiudete portati nelle nostre
vendite però se andate a comprare una
bottiglia d'acqua
qui fuori la pagate euro com'è possibile
che ci sia questa questo scollamento fra
il valore che noi attribuiamo a qualche
cosa da un punto di vista è il valore
che attribuiamo a questo qualche cosa da
un altro punto di vista
ora cerchiamo di capire che cosa che
cosa succede noi abbiamo un input
sinistra che sono materie prime diciamo
materie prime nel senso più generale
delle termine un output destra e in
mezzo succede qualcosa che dà luogo al
prodotto o al servizio o al comparto che
volete
ora questo qualcosa richiede contributo
di risorse risorse che tipicamente
assumono di volta in volta l'aspetto di
energia materia lavoro danaro
informazione questo schema può essere
applicato ad esempio se volete farvi una
casetta di legno
prendete il legname avete bisogno di
attrezzi avete bisogno di informazione
perché dovete sapere come usarli sapere
cosa volete sapere come farlo però può
essere applicato anche a sistemi
completamente differenti questo è
un'università le menti che prende dei
teenager
li trasforma i laureati per far questo
ha bisogno delle stesse cose energia
materia informazione combustibili c'è
ancora bene tutte queste cose però sono
quantificate con unità di misura diverse
e ci insegnano fin da piccolini che non
possiamo sommare per sé come le quindi
per trovare il costo a monte di qualche
cosa ci troviamo difficoltà perché
dobbiamo contabilizzare delle cose che
sono completamente diverse
alcune misurate in euro alcune misurate
in mega byte alcune misurate in
chilowattora bene la scienza ha per
nostra fortuna prodotto un sistema per
fare questa contabilizzazione gli
scienziati non sono solo dei signori
vestiti con dei camici bianchi che
guardano dentro curare di microscopi
l'analisi sistemica ha individuato una
quantità che si chiama energia energia
con la m
la quale consente di contabilizzare
riportando tutte queste quantità la
stessa unità di misura che qui ho
indicato con la sigla s e j
questa persona equivalent ng non voglio
parlare di energia
mi interessa solo sapere l'inglese solo
che se voi sappiate che questa cosa
esiste che questa cosa esiste e che ci
permette virtualmente di calcolare
quanti sj sono serviti
o meglio sono virtualmente contenuti in
un barile di petrolio piuttosto che in
un'ora di lavoro in una bottiglia
d'acqua in una tigre
pensate a quanta informazione è stata
necessaria per produrre la tir e
informazione che immagazzinata adesso
nel suo dna è possibile contabilizzarlo
è possibile è possibile qual è la cosa
che di cui voglio parlarvi oggi nel
momento in cui riuscirà estrarla dal
taschino
la contabilizzazione del costo di questa
pallottola
questo è un proiettile di un fucile
d'assalto che sia un ak47 un kalashnikov
un m16 dell'esercito americano è
assolutamente indifferente cambia
veramente poco questa è una pallottola è
l'idea di provare a calcolare qual è il
costo dell'investimento che ha dovuto
essere compiuto per creare questa
pallottola ci è venuta con con personale
di emergency l'associazione con cui tra
le altre cose collaboro e ha seguito in
un episodio qualche mese fa è stata
portata all'ospedale di kabul
questo è l'ingresso dell'ospedale di
emergency a kabul in afghanistan
una bambina sette anni ancora viva
ripeto ancora viva e sarebbe morta di lì
a poco questa è la radiografia della sua
testa
ora trattandosi di persone che ne vedono
di tutti i colori
il chirurgo che l'ha che la che l'ha
avuta davanti dice che questa veramente
ha fatto dire al personale di emergency
caspita questo è veramente troppo questa
è una rete troppo ora l'inerzia venuta è
proviamo a vedere quanto abbiamo
investito come società insieme alla geo
biosfera ovverossia insieme all'ambiente
naturale per creare questo proiettile e
abbiamo cominciato a fare i conti questo
proiettile tipico vedete è fatto
sostanzialmente dalla pallottola dalla
cartuccia l'esplosivo e l'innesco
l'innesco è un di schino di metallo che
contiene delle sostanze chimiche che
servono come detonante ritardante
accelerante comburente
conservante e quant'altro e che vengono
aggiunte per far funzionare bene
il proiettile la parte metallica è fatta
la combinazione di metalli diversi
dipende anche dalla tipologia di
proiettile
l'esplosivo e nitrocellulosa una cosa
che potete fare anche in casa con in più
tutta una serie appunto di sostanze
chimiche l'innesco il di schino di
metallo tipicamente è fatto da metalli
più queste sostanze chimiche che
torniamo al discorso che federico prima
no tutti queste sostanze chimiche di cui
io francamente non conosco nulla ma
perché le bandierine perché le
bandierine le bandierine sono i paesi
produttori di queste sostanze chimiche e
i paesi presso i quali le fabbriche di
armi comperano queste sostanze chimiche
che entrano in questo proiettile ok
abbiamo cina brasile messico india
l'unione europea gli stati uniti quindi
anche senza la necessità reale di
entrare nel merito del conto del
conteggio voi vedete che per produrre
questo proiettile virtualmente l'intero
mondo è coinvolto l'intero mondo
coinvolto ma non in senso metaforico in
senso fisico in senso fisico
qui c'è l'innesco in questo innesco ci
sono cose che sono state prodotte in
tutto il mondo
quindi estratte come minerale raffinate
messe insieme trasportate e assemblate e
finite nel caso che vi ho mostrato prima
nella testa della bambina di questo
proiettile ne vengono prodotti un sacco
costa 20 centesimi
curiosamente proprio quanto una
bottiglia da un litro di petrolio 20
centesimi lo potete comprare in internet
se in italia fosse consentito detenerlo
voi fate un ordine via web tre scatole 6
euro come arrivano a casa 20 centesimi
l'uno e ne vengono prodotti e 15
miliardi l'anno
15 miliardi l'anno non ovviamente tutti
di un proiettile di questo tipo in
generale dei proiettili delle cosiddette
small hans cioè le piccole armi né 15
miliardi l'anno significa 500 al secondo
quelle sono 500 quali sono 500
ora le leggi di mercato ci dicono che se
nel mercato vengono introdotte 500
oggetti al secondo vuol dire che vengono
consumati 500 oggetti al secondo quindi
vedete che un'analisi anche senza ripeto
la necessità di quantificarla
immediatamente ma solo dicendo la
qualitativa comincia a far sì che voi
poniate delle domande che voi pone altre
domande
di fatto questo è il uno schema tipico
dell'analisi energetica di qualche cosa
ora io non entro nei dettagli che volevo
solo mostrarvi cosa vuol dire definire
un diagramma che comprende i flussi che
concorrono alla produzione di qualche
cosa può essere una pallottola può
essere un servizio può essere l'economia
di un'intera nazione
l'hanno fatto curiosamente per
l'economia della cina e vedete dall'alto
arrivano i flussi tra i flussi c'è
quello di lavoro di servizio
c'è un contributo ambientale c'è un
flusso di danaro a destra che consente
all'intero apparato di portare questa
pallottola dalla testa dell'ingegnere
che l'ha progettata al mercato e da
questa la testa della bambina la testa a
testa l'idea dell'ingegnere arriva alla
testa della bambina
quindi anche se qui si vede forse un po
male in alto a sinistra avete i
giacimenti minerari e tutto l'immenso e
altamente tecnologico lavoro che viene
fatto per l'estrazione di minerali che
come abbiamo visto vengono da tutto il
mondo e quindi hanno una necessità di
trasporto vengono trasportati via nave
via camion via treno eccetera eccetera
viene usato del territorio quindi c'era
un contributo ambientale come minimo
nella misura contributo a monte intendo
come minimo nella misura in cui per
farsi una fabbrica di pallottole devo
utilizzare del territorio e quello che
poi rientra in quello che si chiama
ecologico il footprint l'impronta
ecologica no il territorio che uso per
fare le le le nelle mie attività
oltre a questo chiaramente c'è bisogno
poi di materie prime di altro tipo acqua
tanta acqua qualsiasi fabbrica utilizza
molto
acqua elettricità energia combustibili e
una fabbrica che sintetizza le sostanze
chimiche che deve usare tutto questo
entra nella fabbrica vera e propria c'è
del lavoro
vedete ci sono gli operai ci sono i
quadri dirigenti ci sono i manager e c'è
l'ingegnere che lui in alto a destra
quello che saluta vedete l'ingegnere che
virtualmente ha immaginato questo tipo
di pallottola c'è una spesa per
l'ingegnere certo che c'è perché perché
in un'università pubblica come in italia
noi abbiamo pagato per educarlo noi
abbiamo pagato per istruirlo quindi da
un punto di vista sociale
c'è un costo a monte che tra le altre
cose include anche l'ingegnere che poi
ha avviato diciamo così virtualmente
tutto il tutta la catena di dvd processi
poi all'interno della fabbrica ci
saranno macchinari ci sarà un altoforno
per la fusione ci saranno delle
stampatrici ci saranno i materiali per
ufficio un fax telefoni ci sarà la
segreteria ci saranno i servizi per
pulire ci sarà la mensa quindi ruota
attorno a questo chiaramente un un
apparato di cui tutto virtualmente va
tenuto conto per capire quanto costa
dal punto di vista che abbiamo visto
prima il proiettile ea valle di questo
chiaramente poi ci deve essere una
costruzione del consenso politico che
passa attraverso ovviamente ai mezzi di
comunicazione di massa e da ultimo
chiaramente tutta una serie di
trasmissioni di valuta che coinvolge
currency diverse perché coinvolge paesi
diversi per fare in modo di arrivare
alla fine a questa fotografia questa che
radiografia
ora qual è il messaggio sedi messaggio
si può parlare è evidente che questa
immagine è inaccettabile sotto tutti i
punti di vista da qualsiasi lato voi la
guardia te non è accettabile
non è accettabile bene quello che io
vorrei in assoluta modeste suggerirvi è
proprio di cominciare a ragionare a
chiedervi non sulla base dello user side
perspective cioè della prospettiva
dell'utente ma provare quando vedete un
pezzo di realtà attorno a voi di cui non
capite bene cosa sta sotto provare
metterli dall'altra parte
ora io non vi ho dato poi il risultato
numerico di quanti sig costa la
pallottola ma non è e non è rilevante
perché il messaggio non è quello di una
risposta che io voglio darvi vi dico
semplicemente che ponendosi la domanda
con cui è partito il mio talk spesso
spesso riusciamo cominciare a costruire
anche una risposta